I think it's artists and acting coach
said this to me my first acting coach
out here I'll never forget and he's very
true very you know very right about it
but actors as artists are traditionally
the most um under practiced under
practice and by that he meant like
musicians practice for hours they don't
just show up at carnegie hall and expect
to play like these i mean their masters
right like they rehearse every day hours
a day painters paint you know um you
know writers right but actors are
notorious for thinking well I can just
go to the gym and get my sides the day
before read and then go into my audition
and book it but they don't put in a lot
of work before that you know which our
class is over herzing or you know that
that type of stuff and I'm guilty of it
too believe me I mean I'll be the first
to admit it but like that's a constant
struggle I think you know so sometimes
sometimes I think while networking is
also great like as actors we need to you
know also be putting in the work work
counts you know I mean where it matters
and like I said we are artists so like
there's a big ownership you know that
that we have to earn with that title and
and I think you know traditionally like
actors are a little bit more on the you
know the flexible that the the easy side
of that you know like that we don't work
as hard as some of the other artists you
know our other kind of parts out there
for sure
you